foreign
Joe is on the line in Jersey City New
Jersey Joe how can we help
Hey Kevin Hey Jade how are you guys
we're having a blast as you can tell
what's going on
uh well I just wanted to say Ken great
stuff as always and uh Jay
congratulations and good luck hey thanks
Joe
uh yeah so my question is um now that
the market has kind of gone you know
Wayward over the last few years with
pandemic and everything and inflation
and cost of living and all that has kind
of gotten up in almost the entire
country just wondering does have you
guys considered has Dave considered the
um emergency the starter emergency fund
to go up maybe to like 1500 or 2000
because some prices for things like a
hot water heater or transmission
whatever it might be more expensive than
it used to be oh he wrote the book
originally and started this plan now
this is funny Jade this is like does the
emergency fund baby step one need an
inflationary adjustment very thoughtful
question will it say well whose side are
you on here Ken what I didn't take a
side I just said it's a very interesting
question everything else is hitting
everything else is being adjusted for
inflation I think it's a thoughtful
question it is a thoughtful question and
and here's where I'm gonna approach this
because you're not the first person to
ask this Joe and I'm sure you're not
going to be the last person to ask that
question but what we have found is that
when we ask when we teach for folks to
get a thousand dollars saved most people
and I mean the statistics will tell you
that 56 of Americans do not cannot
afford a thousand dollar that's right
emergency wow and we actually did a
study on the state of personal finance
and it told us that 36 of Americans
actually have zero dollars
zero zero some might call it a goose egg
no money saved so if you have a thousand
dollars do you know what that's called
Joe that's called winning at life
because most people just don't have it
so where I can understand the mindset
because trust me I have kids you know we
got cars we got there's a lot that can
go wrong and I understand that but
understanding what the what the averages
are and understanding what the actual
truth of the matter is which is most
folks don't have any money saved if they
have an emergency they're going straight
to their credit cards all right and
they're taking an emergency and just
turning it into a even bigger problem
with zeros on the end and so what we're
trying to teach is is an accessible way
for you to plan for emergencies and
we've found that a thousand dollars is
something that if you bust your butt and
get it saved it's actually enough to to
float you through now here's the thing
it's not intended to feel like all right
I've made it in life I can just sit back
and put my feet up put my drawer put my
Jordans up on the desk right there it is
that's not what it's for you know we
want you to feel that that that anxiety
not anxiety but we want you to feel that
that feeling of I got to get out of this
like this is not where I want to stay
and that should light your fire to get
through baby step two so that you can
have that three to six months and have
that cushy feeling and that that
wonderful feeling of security how does
that sit with you Joe
no that's uh that's fine you notice I'm
I'm kind of getting started with the uh
baby steps I've known about it for a
while but um you know the wife and I
would you know trying to come to uh
understanding an agreement on how to how
to go about it and yeah we haven't even
just talked about this uh step number
one and I know that
um my wife might feel more comfortable
as Dave Lloyd tell us about the security
gland oh yeah yeah he's gonna come up
and I think you know I just want to have
an idea so what would be said Hey Joe I
presented the whole baby stuff to her
she kind of likes it but yeah yeah let
me ask you a question how much debt do
you have to pay off
uh quite a bit I got about
um my wife has uh under her name but
it's ours obviously I understand that um
it's about uh oh just under a hundred
thousand I think in uh student loans um
and then we have about maybe uh another
30-ish in um credit card or uh Consumer
Debt okay so I want to address your
wife's Comfort gland because you're
bringing up a very good point and you're
gonna I have to communicate that she's
got to be on board so I want to give you
just something from a husband's point of
view on that conversation so let's just
forget for the moment the hundred
thousand in student loan debt let's look
at the credit card debt or Consumer Debt
of 30 000 okay if you were to pay off
one or two of those credit cards okay
how much money would that bring back to
your budget so in other words how much
you paying out on the thirty thousand
dollars what would you say ballpark
figure of the thirty thousand not
student loan how much are you paying out
each month in minimums or whatever
oh well uh uh well without the mortgage
it's try it's about uh like
1500 all right that's what I'm looking
for on mine yeah all right so my point
is if you guys got really intense and
you paid off thirty thousand dollars
that's fifteen hundred dollars a month
that you don't have to put out you
understand what I'm saying it's a mental
thing now we want you putting that money
into the student loan so you're gonna
debt snowball this thing but I'm just
trying to help her see we're gonna have
more you have more than you think you
got more than you think once we pay off
some of the debt so the safety gland
needs to be focused on whoa we need to
build up some protection and the
protection is not the savings the
protection is getting rid of the debt
that's the it I'm not trying to play
mind games with your with with you and
your wife but she needs to understand
why we need to be all in on this yeah
have you guys done Financial Peace
University
[Music]
uh I I went through I would do some of
the classes I haven't gone to the
following um and my life is going to
yeah I want you guys to go through that
together and that's going to get her on
the same page with you because that's
key if you want to get this debt paid
off you wanted to be on the same page
Financial Peace will teach you how to do
that